♪ Yet the fire still jumping ♪
♪ And the cotton still fried ♪
- Dominique Fils-Aimé, vous êtes
née à Montréal de parents
haïtiens, mais on peut dire que
vous êtes la fille spirituelle,
d'une certaine façon, d'Ella
Fitzgerald et de Nina Simone.
Est-ce que vous vous souvenez
la première fois que
vous les avez entendues,
ces grandes chanteuses-là?
- Je me rappelle... En fait,
ma soeur a une quantité de CD
industrielle parce qu'elle
travaillait dans la musique.
Les premières fois, j'étais très
jeune. Je me rappelle écouter
les CD la nuit, mais sur
"repeat" constamment.
♪ Some day he'll come along,
The man I love ♪
♪ And he'll be big and strong,
Billie Holiday, B.B. King,
Nina Simone, même Bob Marley,
tous ces artistes qui avaient...
qui parlaient avec leurs
émotions, qui chantaient
avec leur coeur. Et c'est pas
la musique d'aujourd'hui
où tout est fait à l'ordi,
où tout est parfait.
C'est pas cette recherche
de perfection-là. C'était
une recherche de perfection dans
l'expression de leur émotion
et de ce qu'ils ressentaient
à ce moment-là. Et ça m'a...
pour moi, c'était magique.
T'sais, la nuit, les yeux
fermés, c'était complètement
magique et t'as l'impression
qu'ils te parlent à toi,
qu'ils savent comment tu te
sens. T'es moins seul en fait.
Tu te rends compte que
la musique, la personne,
elle fait juste te raconter :
voilà comment je me suis senti.
Toi tu fais : ah mon Dieu!
Mais moi aussi! Des fois,
ils te racontent des émotions
que t'as même pas encore vécues,
mais tout d'un coup,
tu les comprends.
♪ You're a no good
Heartbreaker ♪
♪ You're a liar
And you're a cheat ♪
Comme Aretha Franklin avait
une chanson qui disait
Heartbreaker, qui disait comment
elle s'était fait briser
le coeur et je n'avais eu aucune
peine d'amour dans ma vie.
T'sais, j'avais genre 13 ans,
mais je ressentais la douleur.
Ah! Je savais déjà qu'est-ce que
ça allait être. Évidemment,
c'était ça. C'est exactement ça.
Quand j'ai grandi, j'ai dit :
wow! OK, elle, elle l'a chanté,
elle m'a montré c'était quoi,
comme ça, je savais déjà.
Quand ça m'arrive :
ah! c'est ça! OK. Donc oui,
c'est assez magique.
- J'ai beaucoup aimé
votre deuxième album.
- Merci.
- Je ne suis pas le seul
d'ailleurs, je pense.
- Je suis chanceuse, les gens...
quelques personnes l'aiment bien
à date.
- Comment vous expliquez que
ça ait aussi bien fonctionné
sur ce deuxième album-là?
Parce que c'est toutes
vos compositions, dans le fond.
- Exact. Oui, c'est toutes
mes compositions, mais
je me dis, quelque part, c'est
comme s'il ne m'appartenait pas
vraiment. Dans le sens où j'ai
tellement pris toute l'histoire
du jazz et l'histoire des Noirs
et de la révolution pour
m'inspirer, pour essayer de
créer un message qui était
plein d'amour et d'espoir,
que c'est pas vraiment à moi.
C'est comme un transcrit,
un peu, de ce que j'ai compris
de cette histoire-là pour
l'amener aujourd'hui en 2019.
♪ Something here
don't feel right ♪
♪ Cause you don't
treat me right ♪
♪ You don't treat me
like the queen ♪
♪ You keep telling me you see ♪
- Justement, qu'est-ce
qu'on peut comprendre
avec cette histoire-là? Puis,
pourquoi elle est importante,
cette histoire-là, pour vous?
- Pour moi, elle est importante
parce que c'est pas si loin
encore, dans notre histoire
collective et dans notre mémoire
collective, des moments de
grande violence et de fermeture
d'esprit entre humains.
De fermeture de portes entre
humains. Et d'après moi,
on avance seulement à partir
du moment où on s'unit
et qu'on reconnaît la force
de chacun et qu'on est plus
forts ensemble en fait.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Plusieurs vous ont découvert
à l'émission La Voix.
Mais j'ai un peu l'impression
que c'était pas vraiment vous,
cette émission-là.
Est-ce que je me trompe?
- En effet, La Voix,
c'est quand même très spécial,
vu que c'est des covers.
Et moi j'aime beaucoup créer
des originales. Mais comme
j'étais déjà partie et que j'ai
eu l'opportunité de découvrir
ce monde-là, je trouve qu'il y a
beaucoup de leçons à en tirer.
C'est comme une école intensive
où t'apprends tout en condensé,
très vite, très intense.
Et t'en ressors et là, t'es
libre de faire ce que tu veux
avec les outils que ça t'a
amenés en fait. Donc pour moi,
c'était une expérience
vraiment grandissante.
- C'est une grosse machine.
- C'est une grosse machine,
mais faite d'humains.
Ça, je le répète souvent.
T'sais quand on pense à des
machines, on pense à un côté
froid. Mais j'ai rencontré
tellement de belles personnes,
que je côtoie encore aujourd'hui
et qui m'ont beaucoup inspirée,
qui m'ont permis de passer
à travers ce processus.
- Maintenant, l'international
vous attend. Quelle est
votre stratégie, justement,
pour sortir du Québec
et rayonner partout? Parce que
la compétition est quand même
féroce dans ce milieu-là, non?
- Non.
- Ah non?
- Non. La compétition,
c'est une illusion totale.
Parce qu'à partir du moment
où chaque personne s'exprime,
elle a gagné. Déjà pour moi,
c'est ça, le but étant
de s'exprimer, de vivre
ce qu'on aime. T'sais, donc,
ça c'est le plus gros cadeau
que personne peut avoir. Puis
j'ai déjà travaillé ailleurs,
ce qui m'a rendu malheureuse.
J'avais beau avoir plus d'argent
et plus de stabilité, j'étais
pas heureuse, et on a juste
une vie à vivre. Donc pour moi,
n'importe qui qui prend le temps
de faire ce qu'il aime
et de pousser, il a gagné.
Et la compétition, elle est
toujours avec nous-même.
De devenir la meilleure personne
qu'on peut devenir.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Message entendu. Dominique
Fils-Aimé, merci beaucoup.